السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته الواحد
بيحس بفقر ان العالم افتكرنا خلاص من سنه
1930 بقى فيه هناك دوله عربيه اسلاميه
عشان كده انا حابب بقى الاستوديو بتاعنا
بايه قرانيه يا ايها الناس انا خلقناكم من
ذكر وانثى وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا
ان اكرمكم عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم
خبير يعرفونا
واحكموا علينا كويس بلد عربي اسلامي بينظم
حدث كبير عالمي اللي هيعرف قطر ويزور قطر
هيقع في حب قطر
كاكا بقى له ثلاث اربع ايام لابس عنابي
شكرا لقطر والعالم مدين باعتذار لقتل وقطر
ان شاء الله سوف تظهر العالم وسوف نفتخر
بها كعرب وكمسلمين ان دوله عربيه اسلاميه
تعتز بالهويه بتاعتها وبتقاليدها
وبقوانينها وانت تقولي نعم
انا اتمنى لها التوفيق والنبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم
اللهم من اراد بقطر سوء فاجعل كيده في
نحره الله وان اراد بقطر خير فوفقه الى كل
خير
[تصفيق]